you can hear a Meister coming long
before you see him thanks to the
jangling chains he's forced to wear
around his neck it's meant to remind him
of his servitude like the collar of a
dog he can't remove it even to sleep
each link signifies mastery or at least
what those withered old men in the
Citadel consider mastery of a different
area of study gold for the study of sums
and accounts silver for healing iron for
war black iron for Raven rhe LED for
poisons and Valyrian steel for the
higher mysteries only one maester in 100
forges such a link only one maester in a
hundred has the sense the gods gave a
goat though I admit that no one has
performed true magic in centuries we sit
in a room mumbling over a candle of
dragonglass
trying to make it catch fire after a
sleepless night of failure we're
supposed to admit to our own limitations
to win the link we are supposed to lose
our curiosity I never did in time the
arch masters decided more links were
useless to a man who wouldn't be chained
by them they took my chain and expelled
me from the Citadel their loss the chain
as a whole is supposed to signify the
realm one cannot have only lords or only
Knights on these farmers Smith's
merchants shepherds and the like like a
chain forged of many different metals an
obvious and trivial point disguised with
pomposity much like the maesters
themselves they study without learning
and proudly pass down the same knowledge
that was passed down to them with no
addition perhaps such is to be expected
when one considers the kinds of men who
become masters the youngest sons of
noble families dutiful and timid raised
in the shadow of their older brothers or
bastards and peasant boys whose minds
are easily satisfied by the knowledge of
their next meal
because bold men will not be chained
they dare to ask questions that the
maesters fear to answer they will look
at a living man and ask how and they
will look at the dead and ask what if